a recent study revealed that about two
million
kids are going to sleep each night
without a bed of their own
well after our next guest learned about
this need he decided to start building
beds
for kids in his community and six years
later
he has provided over 400 beds
to families and his name is robert
bosquez
and he's an elementary school custodian
and i am
so honored that he is joining us today
robert hi drew
hi robert we're so excited to have you
and your community spotlighted here on
the show
when we read that you said there is an
invisible
need for this can you explain that how
did you learn about this
tell us everything sure so you know
six years ago when we started this
program
uh we we myself included didn't know
that there was this you know this hidden
need
so we reached out to a local
not-for-profit here in town
they provide furniture for families here
in town we asked them what is your
number one request
right away they said beds so i was like
okay well you know what let's do some
fundraising
we fundraise to build uh 40 beds and i
said let's let's
put an application out and let's see how
many we get and we received over a
hundred
that told me right there that you know
what this need here in town is a need
that we need to fulfill
and in 2015 you began building and
donating beds
to those families and others like how
does the program work
so every fall we put an application out
and once we receive them we always
receive way more than we can provide
um and some of these stories that we
hear
you know they're so heart touching it's
difficult right to tell a family i'm
sorry but
we can't provide you a bet but the
rewarding part is when we invite these
families so we invite these families
that are chosen to come and help build
along
and the excitement of the families
receiving you know some of these kids
are sleeping in a bed for the first time
and
when you make these beds i understand
that you
take care of every aspect of it right so
they're not just getting a mattress
right correct yeah so when we build we
invite them to build we build the frame
uh they get a mattress they get the
sheets they get the pillow
they get a quilt but they get laundry
detergent
books and a teddy bear so they get a
whole package it's not just the bed
i love what you are doing and thinking
of
every brilliant touch
and what is it that you guys are
often in need of most in order to do
this
well as is you know we all know
mattresses are the most expensive part
of this
and uh recently you know the last couple
years we reached out to a local
furniture store here in town and
and this year it's just going to be hard
it's going to be tough because we all
know
with the pandemic you know everybody's
been been hit so hard that
the ass this year is going to be really
tough even if we even ask
i understand and um our friends at
uh simmons actually reached out to us
and today
they're gonna gift you 30 brand new
twin mattresses worth over seven
thousand dollars
and more friends of ours tuft and needle
is going to provide 30 sheet sets that
are brand new
i'm so happy and i thank simmons and
tufts and needle
for stepping up to the plate for wanting
to be a part of this
for enabling robert to do what
it is that you do and you really are
a superhero saving the world one
bed one family one whole set up at a
time
and we just thank you so much for that
thank you drew for for having us and uh
i just i i can't thank you enough um our
committee thanks you as well
do you um ever get to do anything for
yourself
and your wife and i think you guys have
an anniversary coming up
any plans uh no no not yet um
yeah it's our 25th year anniversary uh
my wife is a wonderful human being
of course you know none of this is is
possible without
uh her support um so as of right now we
don't have any plans um but
you know we'll just uh sit back and
relax and enjoy our 25th annual
anniversary and
we'll see what happens next year well
guess what robert you have some plans
now because the ihg hotels and resorts
one of the largest hotel groups
want to give you and your wife a
luxurious vacation to the
intercontinental presidente
cozumel resort and spa and it's located
right on the coast of mexico
amid one of the world's largest coral
reef systems
and it's all taken care of during your
six night seven-day trip
and meals and flights all done all you
have to do is snorkel
and enjoy and recharge the batteries so
that you can keep doing what you're
doing
[Applause]
i'm just we're all so inspired by what
you're doing here
and you're so amazing
well thank you jew and again every year
what
what recharges my batteries if i can
share this story
uh we had a family come they rented a
u-haul because they wanted to make sure
that they had transportation to take
these beds home
i was two young girls and uh
the excitement of these girls putting
these beds together you know we could
you could just see it
and once the bed was finished we put the
mattress on there and we put all the
sheeting and the pillows and
and she took that teddy bear she gave it
a big
bear hug and just fell back into the bed
and that right there from that moment on
told me guess what you're going to be
doing this every year
thank you robert for being you is the
only thing i can think of and
if there's any way that you can multiply
yourself or teach us all how to be more
like you
please do so because you're amazing
well go to our website to learn more
about robert's bed blitz program
so that you can get involved we want to
simmons and tuft and needle are getting
involved
and um it's it's game on uh all in honor
of robert and his incredible work
you